hi und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid und wenn
ihr euch gerade fragt warum sieht das
alles so anders aus dann kann ich euch
sagen dass wir heute eine sehr besondere
Sendung machen denn wir sind live auf
der Digital messere publica in Berlin
und vielleicht hört jetzt so ein
bisschen im Hintergrund hier ist richtig
viel los vor uns sitzt auch Publikum das
ist für diese Sendung sehr ungewöhnlich
weil normalerweise gucke ich eigentlich
nur in die Kamera und stelle mich euch
dahinter vor und wie ihr jetzt gerade
seht sitzen auch so ein paar heute Leute
und hören uns äh live zu am Inhalt
verändert das jetzt erstmal gar nicht so
viel in dieser besonderen Sendung waren
wir zum einen wie immer auf die aktuelle
Nachrichtenlage gucken und das auch zu
einem der Themen was die bei ZDF heute
live ständig Geschehen nämlich den
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine und die
Nachrichtenlage heute ist wie folgt das
moskau ist angeblich gelungen sei eine
ukrainische Großoffensive im südlichen
Teil des Gebietes Donuts zu veraltet
dazu gab es aber aus dem russischen
Militär schon Widerspruch und Kiew
bestätigt gleichzeitig dass es offensive
Aktionen gibt dementiert aber diese
Rückschläge auf der anderen Seite wollen
wir diese Sendung heute nutzen um so ein
bisschen die bisherige Ukraine
Berichterstattung auf Youtube mit mir
mit meinen Kolleginnen und mit euch da
draußen Revue passieren zu lassen und so
ein bisschen zu diskutieren was sind
eigentlich die Chancen aber auch die
Herausforderungen von über einem Jahr
Kriegsberichterstattung auf Youtube und
ihr seht wir haben eine ganze Menge vor
und ich muss das zum Glück nicht alleine
machen wir sprechen heute mit Ukraine
Reporter Tim Kröger der uns live aus der
Ukraine aus saporisa zugeschaltet ist
wir sprechen mit dem militär-experten
Christian möhling von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik der
hier live bei mir sitzt auch ungewohnte
Situation herzlich willkommen danke
und mit ZDF heute live Teamleiter Gregor
Burkhard und natürlich das hat sich
nicht verändert wie immer auch mit euch
wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt wenn ihr
Fragen an unsere Expertinnen habe oder
einfach eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns
teilen wollt dann tut das wie äh immer
gerne einfach im Youtube Chat oder an
die jetzt eingeblendete Mailadresse ja
und damit wir erstmal alle auf den
gleichen Stand kommen gucken wir uns ein
Stück von Christian Volk an der hat uns
zusammengefasst was ist mit der
Nachrichtenlage heute auf sich hat
verwackelte Aufnahmen einer russischen
Drohne sie sollen den Beschuss von
ukrainischen Panzerfahrzeugen zeigen das
Verteidigungsministerium in Moskau
meldet Angriff abgewehrt die Ukraine
habe in einer groß angelegten Offensive
fünf Punkte im Süden des Landes
attackiert nahe der Front statt wuchle
da die Lage unübersichtlich ein für das
Gebiet zuständiger russischer Kommandeur
widerspricht den Erfolgsmeldungen aus
Moskau und auch Militärexperten sind
skeptisch
das ist aber keine operative Offensive
das ist ein praktisches Geplänkel also
ein Gefecht dass ich ja noch nicht voll
entwickelt hat da muss man noch abwarten
man kann ja in wenigen Stunden eine
größere Offensive überhaupt nicht
entwickeln sehen sondern dass wir Tage
und vielleicht sogar Wochen in Anspruch
nehmen diese Meldung die aus Russland
kommt ist zwei los verfrüht und
wahrscheinlich auch nicht richtig die
Ukraine bestätigt Angriffe in einigen
Frontabschnitten ein gestern
veröffentlichtes armee-video soll aber
zeigen eine Großoffensive Willie nicht
ankündigen
und darüber sprechen wir jetzt live mit
Ukraine Reporter Tim Krüger der jetzt
gerade live in saporija steht hallo Tim
herzlich willkommen auf der Republica
schönen guten Tag aus der policia
Tim was ist denn deine Einschätzung zu
dieser Gemengelage die wir da heute
haben Russland vermeldet Erfolge bzw
Rückschläge die Ukraine äußert sich erst
gar nicht dementiert das dann aber wie
ist deine Einschätzung
also ich werde zunächst mal äußerst
vorsichtig mit den verlautbaren die wir
da aus Moskau vernommen haben vom
russischen Verteidigungsministerium da
ist von einer exorbitanten Zahl von
getöteten ukrainischen Soldaten die Rede
von zerstörten Panzern von zerstörten
ukrainischen Militärgerät das würde ich
auf jeden Fall mal sehr im Zweifel
ziehen vor allem eben deswegen weil es
auch ganz andere teilweise auch pro
russische Quellen gibt die sagen dass
dieser Angriffe seitens der Ukraine
durchaus positiv verlaufen sind im
Großen und Ganzen ist die
Gesamtsituation entlang der Front im
Moment sehr schwer einzuschätzen wir
würden wissen eigentlich nur dass es
Angriffe gegeben hat seitens der Ukraine
das ist auch ganz offenbar ukrainische
Vorstöße gegeben hat und ähm das müssen
wir halt erstmal so als gegeben
hinnehmen die andere Sache ist halt dass
wenn wir uns vorstellen dass diese
Angriffe womöglich eine also dass wir
einfach nicht wissen ob dieser Angriffe
eine kleine kleinere taktische Operation
sind oder eben dann doch der Beginn der
größeren Offensive das was in der
Ukraine lange angekündigt worden ist
dann wissen wir es im Moment einfach
nicht die ukrainische stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin hat sich heute
geäußert und hat gesagt oder hat
zumindest bestätigt dass es ganz
offenbar
seitens der Ukraine seitens der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte offensive
Aktionen gibt dass die Streitkräfte zu
offensiven Aktionen in einigen Vektoren
übergegangen ist sie sagt aber dass
diese Aktion im Moment noch eher lokale
Bedeutung haben und dass diese Aktion
sich vor allem auch im Moment noch auf
Bach Mut beziehen dass das sozusagen das
Zentrum ist das sind schon mal einige
Informationen die wir davon ukrainischer
Seite bekommen haben aber wir wissen
eben noch nicht wie das ganze Bild
aussieht da müssen wir sicherlich noch
etwas warten bis wir da klar sehen
also zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch viel
Spekulation du war
ST ja das ist gar nicht so weit weg von
wuchle da was hast du dort erlebt
das ist eine dieser frontstädte
frontorte entlang der Front hier in
saporicia ungefähr sieben acht Kilometer
von der Front entfernt das ist ein Ort
der im Grunde seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges schon attackiert
bombardiert wird und wir waren da in
einem Versorgungspunkt in einem Keller
eines Wohnhauses und haben dort gesehen
wie dort die Menschen die immer noch in
diesem Ort ausharren sich eben mit
Lebensmitteln versorgen können wie sie
mal waren duschen können wie sie ihre
Sachen waschen können weil es gibt es
eben nicht warmes Wasser und Strom seit
mehr als einem Jahr in diesem Ort Pole
und da sind wir eben auch mit den
Menschen ins Gespräch gekommen und haben
schon gemerkt wie zermürben die
Gesamtsituation vor allem an diesen in
diesem frontstädten ist wir haben zwei
ältere Frauen kennengelernt die uns dann
auch gezeigt haben wo sie seit mehr als
einem Jahr wohnen bzw vor allem schlafen
das ist nämlich ein man muss es so sagen
ein Kellerloch wo das Wasser hineinläuft
wenn es regnet wo ähm die Wände Husten
bei den ganzen Winter über darin mit
einem Ofen geheizt wurde also eine sehr
unangenehme Situation und diese beiden
Frauen haben uns eben erzählt dass es
schon sehr vermögend ist dass die Nerven
schon blank liegen nach diesem Jahr
permanenten Beschuss ist die eine Frau
hat auch ihren 50-Jährigen Sohn durch
einen Raketenangriff verloren und sie
wünschen sich natürlich nichts lieber
als dass dieser Krieg endlich vorbei
geht und dann eben auch in ihren Sinne
das heißt also dass die Ukraine
siegreich aus diesem Krieg hervorgeht
damit eben vor allem die Menschen in
diesen frontstädten dann endlich wieder
in Frieden leben können
danke schön für deine Eindrücke und
alles Gute
ja und über diese aktuellen Meldungen
spreche jetzt natürlich auch mit
Militärexperte Christian Mölling einen
oft gesehener Gast bei uns in der
Sendung von der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für auswärtige Politik noch mal herzlich
willkommen schön dass Sie bei uns sind
was ist denn ihre Einschätzung zu dieser
Gemengelage die wir da heute haben ist
das russische Propaganda wie ist das
einzuschätzen
also ich fand es interessant dass diese
Meldung dann doch heute in den
Morgenstunden doch so einen großen Raum
eingenommen hat auch in den deutschen
Medien auch in den ich sag mal seriösen
Mädchen sozialen Medien wo das dann
kolportiert worden ist
wenn man sich vor Augen führt dass die
Meldung aus dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium gekommen ist
dann über die russische
Nachrichtenagentur weiter verbreitet
worden ist muss man die Informationen
doch stark im Zweifel ziehen zumal ist
ja doch ein klang schon sehr aufgebaut
was da drin war und das passt das ist
sozusagen der zweite informationsbit wo
man dann sehr vorsichtig sein muss es
passt irgendwie nicht zur
gesamtgemängelage dass das jetzt
passiert sein soll dann kam irgendwie
auch die Meldung dass dann der
Oberpfälzer aber der russischen Truppen
auch vor Ort gewesen wäre das war was
okay das jetzt ein bisschen zu viele
eigentlich ne und so kann man eigentlich
an dem Punkt aber nur sagen warum
Verlauf des Tages heute zu den
interview-anfragen nichts Genaues weiß
man nicht und das macht keinen Sinn da
jetzt erstmal was rein zu sagen wie
gesagt ich war sehr überrascht dass die
deutschen Medien das so aufgegriffen
haben das auch nicht stark
kontextualisiert haben gesagt haben das
ist nach russischen Angaben wäre das so
ja ähm wo man so seine Informationen
herbezieht und wie man solche Quellen
auch verifiziert darüber sprechen wir
gleich noch im zweiten Teil der Sendung
lass uns noch mal lassen wir uns noch
mal kurz auf Belgorod schauen das ist
diese russische Stadt die relativ nah an
der Grenze zur Ukraine ist wo es in den
letzten Wochen Meldung gab dass
sogenannte antiputin Russen quasi
Anschläge oder Angriffe in Russland
selbst
ja vornehmen oder ausführen da gab es
jetzt auch wieder eine Meldung dass das
gestern wieder passiert sein soll wie
ist das denn zu bewerten was bedeutet
das jetzt gerade für den Krieg ja ich
glaube man kann immer versuchen solche
Informationen sind in drei Kategorien
einzuteilen das eine ist sozusagen das
was militärisch das bedeutsame daran ist
dass was politisch daran bedeutsam ist
sowohl sagt man Kiefer in Moskau als
auch bei den westlichen Gesellschaften
und das dritte ist der reine
Informationswert oder das was sozusagen
auf der informations oder sagen weil er
einfach Propaganda eben mit damit
fabriziert wird im Grunde genommen ja
wenn man das einstuft da muss man sagen
militärisch ist dadurch nicht viel
gewonnen es versetzt aber Russland
möglicherweise in der Dilemma Situation
dass man sich überlegen muss müssen wir
jetzt Truppen dahin abkommandieren das
müssen keine Soldaten sein das kann auch
Nationalgarde sein aber es ist erstmal
ein Dilemma und es wird durch die
Verquickung mit dem Informationsraum der
Propaganda wird es halt ein zusätzliches
Dilemma weil man diese Informationen
immer aus den eigenen sozialen Medien
den den Chat-Kanälen den telegrams sich
raushalten konnte und man steht
natürlich als der Kreml ein bisschen
peinlich da wenn man sein eigenes Land
und die Grenze nicht schützen kann das
ist sozusagen der die kleine Spitze die
da einfach nur mit drin liegt was das
politisch wiederum in Moskau bedeutet
ist immer sehr schwer eins zu sortieren
ob das jetzt sozusagen die
Tagesaktualität tatsächlich schon eine
große Relevanz für den Krieg hat ich
würde sagen in diesem Punkt erstmal noch
nicht aber die Tatsache dass es immer
wieder passiert kannst sagen einmal ist
keinmal aber wenn das sozusagen
dauermuster wird dann wird es
möglicherweise schwierig
bei ZDF heute live
schon gab er die Frage Frage ist das
jetzt die ukrainische Frühjahrsoffensive
gewesen wann geht sie los sind jetzt
vereinzelte Aktionen die Kiev ja auch
bestätigt schon Teil dieser Offensive
was würden Sie denn sagen wie ist heute
der aktuelle Stand dazu ist sie jetzt
losgegangen
ich würde auch dazu sagen das weiß ich
nicht die Frage ist warum es wichtig ist
aber ich verstehe das sozusagen weil es
dieses Punkt Großoffensive gegen
Offensive sie war früher als Offensive
weil er gesetzt worden ist dreht ist das
der dreh- und Angelpunkt der ganzen
Kommunikation wir würden es nicht wissen
und die Ukraine würde sich auch nicht
vorschreiben lassen wann sie eigentlich
die Offensive beginnt oder wie sie ganz
gerne sehen möchten ich glaube das ist
total wichtig dabei und es ist
sicherlich ein völlig falsches Bild wenn
man denkt da würde jetzt sozusagen
irgendjemand eine Trompete stoßen es
würde losgehen ne also das ist
sicherlich nicht das reale Bild dass man
von dieser Offensive haben wird wir
werden es irgendwann sehen und ich
glaube auch da ist es interessant dass
die sozialen Medien schon ein guter
Indikator teilweise sind weil sie eben
keine Informationen mehr wirklich
gehalten geheim halten können überall
gibt es Smartphones sie werden
irgendwann wenn diese Offensive da ist
dann werden sie sie durchgelegte Videos
sich alle diese Sachen sehen kann aber
natürlich auch immer wiederum sein das
ist fake ist und da kommt eben da drauf
an die unterschiedlichen Witz und peace
seine Informationen zusammenzusetzen und
sagen okay kann es das jetzt sein stimmt
das jetzt und was bedeutet das dann
eigentlich jetzt für die Zukunft
ihr da draußen habt schon eine ganze
Menge Fragen gestellt ich bin hier
gerade schon mal im Job und da gibt es
auch einige die sich an sie richten hier
fragt sie ja auf Youtube wie ist es denn
zu bewerten dass ein russischer
Kommandeur der eigenen Führung
widerspricht das ist ja heute passiert
es gab eine Meldung des russischen
verteidigungsdienstes dass man diese
Erfolge eingeheimt hat und es gab aus
dem russischen Militär quasi schon
Entgegnungen nein das stimmt einfach
nicht jetzt fragt die Userin ist das
normal oder eher außergewöhnlich
das ist ganz schwer einzuschätzen das
ist ja so viele einzelne Informationen
wo jetzt sozusagen die eine die eine
Information das Verteidigungsministerium
hat was gesagt in Russland gegen diese
andere Information gesetzt wo man sagen
muss okay Mark interessant sein aber die
Frage ist ja ist es tatsächlich relevant
natürlich kann man jetzt z.B spekulieren
dass es ähm wir wissen dass die Moral
offensichtlichen russischen Streitkräfte
nicht besonders gut ist und das
natürlich die Leute die an der Front
sind jeden Tag um ihr eigenes Leben zu
kämpfen haben weil sie in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten gesehen
haben dass sie planlos in den Tod
geschickt worden sind und es deswegen
sicherlich nicht nur eine Frustration
auf der intellektuellen Ebene Blick auf
das ist eine Lüge gibt sondern dass man
auch sagt hey die Lage hier ist wirklich
so blöd dass wir jeden Tag sterben
können
hier gibt es noch eine weitere Frage zum
Thema bellgorod hier schreibt jemand auf
Youtube wie hoch ist denn die Gefahr
dass die Lage durch die Angriffe in
Belgorod eskaliert auch in Richtung NATO
EU
das halte ich für gegen Null gehend ich
wüsste nicht wie daraus etwas werden
könnte dass Moskau auf die Idee käme das
gilt für alle diese Fragen die die
Richtung sind was das
eskalationsgefahr etc
Moskau hat ja jetzt schon große Probleme
in diesem Krieg irgendeine seiner Ziele
zu erreichen geschweige denn das
bisschen was man erreicht hat zu halten
dass man sich jetzt einen zweiten Front
aufmacht ist ja erstmal total
unwahrscheinlich also sich im Grunde
noch mehr Ärger ein handelt von daher
würde ich sagen warum sollten sie das
tun das ist ja auch nicht das russische
Interesse das russische Interesse sich
mit der NATO anzulegen das würde ich
auch absolut auf Null setzen dabei kann
man nicht gewinnen die Natur hat auch
gesagt wir wollen es auch nicht also da
gibt's sozusagen da gibt's wirklich eine
rote Linie von daher denke ich das ist
tatsächlich eher was was damit zu tun
hat dass die Ukraine versuchen für
Russland militärische kleine Dilemmata
darzustellen die aber eben auch so eine
informationsdimension haben nur einfach
sagen muss damit lassen wir euch jedes
Mal auch schlecht aussehen wenn wieder
so ein Trupp es schafft ins Land
reinzugehen und wieder zurückzukommen
diese Art der Fragen die haben wir in
den ich glaube letzten 100 es waren auf
jeden Fall über 100 Sendungen oder
Streams zur Ukraine ganz ganz oft
bekommen das sind Fragen die für
Experten wie Sie vielleicht total
selbstverständlich sind für viele von
euch aber nicht und deswegen stellt ihr
oft ähnliche Fragen und ihr stellt vor
allem viele Fragen zu dem Thema und
genau auf diese Art der
Berichterstattung auf eure Fragen auf
die Experten die bei uns in der Sendung
sind möchten wir jetzt mal zurückblicken
und ja ziemlich viele Ukraine Streams
hat mein Kollege Jan Schüssler für uns
zusammengefasst
[Musik]
der Morgen des 24 Februar 2022 ich habe
die Entscheidung für eine
Militäroperation getroffen ich wollte
die ukrainische Streitkräfte im heutigen
Zustand eigentlich für sehr kampfkräftig
und auch die Soldaten sind
offensichtlich gewillt wie auch die
Masse der Bevölkerung ihr Vaterland zu
verteidigen gegen diesen Angriff von
Russland
gekämpft und die ukrainische Armee
kämpft wirklich ja für uns alle und wir
spüren das nicht vorzeitig trauern
deshalb befehle ich dem
Verteidigungsminister und dem
Generalstabschef die nuklearen
abschreckungskräfte der russischen Armee
in höchste Kampfbereitschaft zu
versetzen Heide fragt uns über Youtube
wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
Moskau taktische Nuklearwaffen gegen die
Ukraine einsetzen könnte ich halte den
Einsatz solcher Waffen in der Ukraine
aber speziell im Ballungsräumen für
extrem unwahrscheinlich in der Nachteil
von sogenannten taktischen Nuklearwaffen
also solchen die im Gefechtsfeld
eingesetzt werden ist sie müssen nachher
dadurch erhöhen
eine konkrete Frage an sie soll da drauf
Andreas schreibt über E-Mail mich würde
interessieren was die nächste
Eskalationsstufe von Putin wohl sein
könnte wenn er nicht wie vorgesehen
vorankommt was ja offensichtlich ist
leider leider
die mir putin ist schon immer dafür
bekannt dass er jede Krise versucht
durch eine weitere Eskalationsstufe zu
überwinden
ich habe das selber als Journalistin in
meiner gesamten Laufbahn noch nicht
erlebt dass man Journalisten so nah an
Opfer heranführt diese Groll Taten sind
so unvorstellbar das ist ganz ganz
wichtig ist hier sehr sehr sachlich und
sehr sehr nüchtern nachzuweisen was wir
tatsächlich passiert ist
ich weiß nicht ob alles kollabieren wird
oder etwas sofort aber was wir sehen ist
das viele russische Soldaten weglaufen
[Musik]
wenn Sie noch etwas stärker auf den
Nordteil der Krim hineinzoomen sie sehen
genau dort finden Sie auch die große
Konzentration an diesen Gräben und
Verteidigungsanlagen also sie sehen klar
die Erwartungshaltung wenn es eine
Invasion der Krim gibt dann wird die
wieder so ablaufen wie im Zweiten
Weltkrieg
der Boden sieht mir hier ist noch
vollkommen durchdrängt matschig es ist
nur immer noch nicht die beste Zeit für
eine große Familie
ich kann euch eins sagen wir bei ZDF
heute live bleiben für euch dran danke
für eure Kommentare und bis zum nächsten
Mal
heute live Kriegsberichterstattung auf
Youtube und das wollen wir jetzt
diskutieren ihr seht die Runde hat sich
vergrößert hinzugekommen ist Gregor
Burkhardt Teamleiter von ZDF heute live
und ZDF Reporter daran
Stück gesehen und wir haben auch schon
einige Male miteinander zu der Thematik
gesprochen du bist schon seit 2000 im
Einsatz fürs ZDF kommst eigentlich aus
dem Online Journalismus und hast früh
verstanden das mit dem Fernsehen
Journalismus zu verbinden und bist eben
ganz intensiv in die
Kriegsberichterstattung in der Ukraine
eingebunden du warst alleine über fünf
Monate im letzten Jahr vor Ort auch
dieses Jahr schon zweimal da und du
wirst im Sommer wieder hinfliegen Sarah
wie hast du speziell den Anfang dieses
Krieges erlebt der uns ja alle
eigentlich fassungslos gemacht hat ja
ich war am Anfang genauso überrascht wie
ähm die meisten Menschen das war
unvorstellbar man hat es sich zwar an
den Don Bass Krieg gewöhnt aber man
hatte ja auch immer die Minsker Abkommen
die Verhandlungsposition und man dachte
wahrscheinlich auch wie viele Ukraine
hat das diese
Invasion so in der Härte plötzlich nicht
stattfinden wird als sie dann geschehen
ist
war am Anfang
das Gefühl da dass es fast auf der
Messers Schneide steht dass dieses Land
noch existiert diese Gesellschaft diese
Menschen und es ging auch den Ukrainern
so und so war diese Anfangsphase
Menschen sind geflüchtet und andere sind
haben sofort begonnen ihre Heimatstätte
zu verteidigen das hat man vor allem
nicht nur in Kiew gesehen sondern auch
in Lemberg im Westen es sind kleine
Dörfer gewesen die Bürger werden
gegründet haben die versucht haben sich
militärisch zu schulen um keinen Meter
freizugeben und sich gegen diese
Übermacht zu stellen so war der Anfang
und dann kam
fast so eine Art Ungläubigkeit dass das
funktioniert dass sie diese Offensive
stoppen konnten selensky nicht Kia
verlassen hat dass die
Armee jetzt irgendwie steht und dann kam
diese Phase des Rückzugs und da kam auch
diese Ankündigung relativ früh erinnere
ich mich wie es um die Rückeroberung her
sonst ging die wurde im Sommer
angekündigt und stattgefunden hat sie
dann im Spätherbst und dann war Herbst
und frei und sie fand doch nicht so
statt wie wir auch ich mir das
vorgestellt habe dass panzerrollen das
ähm
Kämpfe um einzelne Siedlungen
stattfanden die gab es zwar vielleicht
aber eigentlich war es ein Rückzug weil
die russische Armee logistisch diese
Position dieses Oblast westlich vom
kniepro nicht mehr halten konnte
ich habe direkt eine Frage aus der
Community von dir von Laura auf Youtube
die
Fragen allgemeine Frage an alle Reporter
in die dort vor Ort sind wie hält man
die Angst aus mittig auf der Straße zu
berichten und wie lange ist man in einem
Stück nah an der Front
also ich kann ja nicht für alle reden
ich sage einfach mal wie es mir ist also
ich habe ganz am Anfang viel mehr Angst
gehabt als ich jetzt habe das lag
einfach daran dass die Situation
komplett neu war
diese dieser massive Krieg dieser
einmalsch den kann ich nicht und damit
habe ich nicht gerechnet
Angst schärft die Sinne es ist gut sie
hält dich davon ab und überlegt es zu
tun was wirklich wichtig ist ähm man hat
auch immer diesen Zwiespalt als Reporter
man will zeigen was vor Ort ist es ist
deine Aufgabe Augen und Ohren zu sein
für die Menschen die zu Hause sind und
damit auch möglichst viel von Fakten zu
übermitteln die für alle für die
Meinungsbildung unterlässlich sind
andererseits ist dann persönliches
Risiko dadurch er kann wirklich schnell
steigen
die Angst selber habe ich mir mit einem
umgekehrten Lottogewinn erklärt ähm und
das hat mich immer sehr beruhigt ich
freue mich auf Glotter wenn ich zu Hause
bin und dann habe ich mir gesagt ja ich
gehe auch nachmittags nicht hin und kauf
mir ein neues Auto nur weil ich morgens
Lotto gespielt habe ich warte die
Ziehung schon mal ab und wenn man dann
das ins andere umkehrt es geht du bist
in deiner Stadt wie z.B wo wir zehn Tage
waren und es war Artilleriebeschuss das
waren jetzt nicht nur
einzelne Luftangriffe die an einem Tag
punktuell stattfanden sondern permanent
und trotzdem wohnt ist das eine
Riesenfläche es ist eine ehemalige Stadt
mit anderthalb Millionen Einwohner
damals waren aber nur 400.000 da die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es dich gerade
trifft ist unwahrscheinlich aber diese
Unwahrscheinlichkeit habe ich selber
erlebt ähm wir sind wie wir dort gewesen
sind zu einem ein Auto ist ein Mann mit
seinem Sohn Gefahren Tempo 35 und ihn
hat eine Artillerie geschossen während
dem Fahren getroffen und das war mitten
auf einer Straße und es war auch ein
fehlgeleiteter Schuss also dort waren
keine russischen Stellungen in der also
es kann passieren also es ist jetzt eine
reale Gefahr aber
der Umgang mit der Angst ist dann glaube
ich das was man für sich dann
hinbekommen muss und man sieht das dass
die Menschen die dort sind es auch
schaffen und wenn man viele tapfere
Leute sieht dann
denkt man ja jetzt weiß ich auch mal auf
die CD und es gibt natürlich auch
Schutzräume und man kann sich auch an so
Sachen auch halten und versuchen die
Gefahr zu minimieren warum dieses Auge
und Ohr für die Menschen vor Ort sein
wichtig ist auch gerade für die Sendung
und gen
erell in ihre Rolle sprechen in den
Medien man hat ja manchmal so ein
bisschen das Gefühl nach der letzten
großen Krise Corona und sämtlichen
corona-expert in die so durch die
Talkshows sind sind so militär-expert in
eigentlich die neuen Menschen die so in
einem in einem vorher vielleicht nie
schicken Interesse auf einmal medial
total präsent sind und sie gehören ja
auch dazu was war das für ein Gefühl das
auf einmal diese Expertise so stark in
medialen Fokus rückt
naja das einzige was es bedeutet das war
erstmal es gibt eine höhere Frequenz in
der man Interviews machen muss das war
sozusagen die die erste initialreaktion
das heißt das erste Jahr war körperlich
sehr anstrengend
aber es hat sich ja sozusagen an der
Expertise in anführungsstrich nichts
geändert im Vergleich mit Corona ist
insofern richtig als das ähm ja auch die
Naturwissenschaftler zwar die
grundmechaniken kennen aber nie eine
genaue Voraussage machen können naja sie
haben ihre Modelle so wie wir unsere
Modell auch haben das heißt aber sehr
kleine Dinge kann jemand der das seriös
betreibt nie Voraussagen was sozusagen
der eine die eine Bewegung jetzt
sozusagen für das große Ganze bedeutet
das ist teilweise sehr sehr schwer zu
sagen deswegen halten wir uns bei diesen
Sachen dann auch wenn es irgendwie geht
zurück so definitive Aussagen zu machen
wenn man sie nicht machen kann ne das
ist äh ne große schwierige Aufgabe da
das richtige Maß zwischen
erklären
und deuten
im Grunde genommen
Militärexperte in irgendeiner Art ein
geschützter Begriff ne das ist ein ein
Begriff der zugeschrieben wird und der
angenommen wird ja Medien und Publikum
schreiben das zu und wir als Experten
haben natürlich auch die Möglichkeit zu
sagen also wollen wir nicht genannt
werden es hilft glaube ich in der
Kommunikation bei der Vereinfachung
total ich hätte mich so nie genannt ich
würde auch niemals das auf meine
Visitenkarte draufschreiben aber es
hilft glaube ich in der Zuordnung in dem
Zusammenhang von daher ist es vollkommen
okay ich glaube die Frage ist immer er
was erwartet man hinter diesem
Expertentum eigentlich wo sind die
Grenzen aber auch das haben wir ja im
letzten Jahr ziemlich hart verhandelt
wir haben ja einige Menschen die
sozusagen öffentlich als Experten
beschrieben werden auch in Talkshow
auftreten und sagen
Auseinandersetzung was dann eine
interessante Vermischung von ich sag mal
im öffentlichen Diskurs das würde seine
Meinung haben kann was total okay ist
das ist Demokratie und auf der anderen
Seite natürlich die Frage ist okay als
Experte habe ich eine Meinung die ich
basieren muss auf Fakten Evidenzen
Modellen also den ganzen Geschichten und
das kommt natürlich im medialen Formaten
irgendwann durcheinander da ist
derjenige der hier sitzt so wie ich auch
ich bin ja weil ich Experte bin ich
könnte ihn jetzt aber irgendeine Meinung
raushauen überhaupt gar keine Evidenz
hat und dann stehen dann steht das
erstmal im Raum es wird weiter
transportiert und das haben wir im
letzten Jahr ziemlich hart verhandelt
auch unter sozusagen den Fachexperten
was sozusagen das alternative Wahrheiten
in dem Sinne eigentlich nicht gehen bei
uns und das ist glaube ich eine
interessante Scheidungsprozess den auch
die Community da durchmachen
also wenn ihr Fragen an unsere Experten
habt dann hebt vielleicht gerne die Hand
und wir lassen eure Frage mit einfließen
Gregor oh wir haben gleich eine Frage
wunderbar ja vielen Dank und Moritz
Respekt vor der großen Aufgabe und auch
die Verantwortung die ihr vor Ort
erfüllt meine Frage von meiner Seite ist
wenn ihr vor Ort seid wie weit habt ihr
die Gelegenheit und die Möglichkeit auch
die Hintergründe Lokal zu recherchieren
und das was später auch berichtet wird
sag mal ursprünglich
mitzugestalten oder habt ihr sozusagen
das Einsammeln von Fakten und Bildern
und das andere wird dann redaktionell
aufgearbeitet
für mich wiederholen ich habe den ersten
Teil verpasst ja ich glaube es ist eine
Frage die sich sehr an Dara richtet der
vor Ort ist ne also es geht darum wie
inwiefern man lokal wenn man vor Ort ist
Hintergründe selber recherchieren kann
verifizieren kann genau ja das ist ja
der Grund weswegen wir hinfahren dass
man es mit eigenen outen Augen sieht
dass man die Atmosphäre wahrnehmen kann
dass man auch hier direkt
nachfragen kann falls sie fixieren ich
gebe jetzt einfach mal ganz konkretes
Beispiel ist mit der Armee in der
Einheit und dann wird einem ein Soldat
vorgestellt und durch ein längeres
Gespräch mit ihm kann man dann
rausfinden ob der jetzt wirklich in den
Kampf einsetzen im Einsatz war oder ob
er im Endeffekt für die
Medienberichterstattung
freigestellt wird für die Armee ist eine
ganz schwierige Sache weil sie
einerseits die ukrainische Armee wünscht
sich Berichterstattung und auf der
anderen Seite für die Truppen vor Ort
sind wir Journalisten ein Stein im Schuh
sie müssen wir unsere Sicherheit sorgen
sie müssen sich kritische Fragen
gefallen lassen und ähm von daher ist
ich sehe keine Alternative außer dorthin
zu gehen es ist deswegen tun wir es ja
auch und gehen auch das Risiko ein ähm
nichts zu ersetzen
vielleicht auch an Dich noch mal die
Frage Gregor die kam auch oft mal in den
Kommentaren wie machen wir das
eigentlich intern im Team also wenn wir
an so einer Sendung arbeiten wie
verifizieren wir denn eigentlich
Berichterstattung die natürlich auch
geprägt ist von Parteilichkeit mal da
verschwimmen vielleicht manchmal die
Quellen wie verifiziert man so
Informationen in dem kriegszeitalter in
einer Redaktion also der erste Punkt das
hat Christian Mölling vorhin
angesprochen ist an Tagen wie heute ist
erstmal Vorsicht geboten wie wie
formulieren wir das und dann versuchen
wir natürlich zu sagen das ist die
russische Seite das ist die ukrainische
Seite das tragen wir zusammen anderes
Beispiel vergangene Woche haben wir ähm
über die
Angriffe auf Moskau bzw die
Drohnenangriffe die Drohnen die dort in
die Stadt geflogen sind in die
Außenbezirke berichtet da laufen im
Laufe des Tages verschiedene Videos
häufig von telegram ein über die
sozialen Medien die vierfach geteilt
werden das ist auch unsere auf aber das
was im Netz sowieso vorhanden ist dass
dann zu überprüfen zu gucken was ist
davon war was ist authentisch da gehen
wir den Tag über durch da haben wir
Kollegen mit den schauen wir gemeinsam
auf diese Videos da gucken wir als
allererstes sind die neu diese Videos
sind die vorher schon mal irgendwo
aufgetaucht im Netz ganz häufig sind das
alte Videos die einfach neu rausgeholt
werden das zweite ist wir schauen da
drauf woher kommen diese Videos
die Ortsbestimmung können wir über
Google Street View sehen dieser Ort ist
da können wir das mit Häusern und so
weiter abgleichen stimmt die Zeit der
Lichteinfall das ist etwas
kompliziertere Sache die dauert auch
schon mal einen Tag bis zum Abend bis
zur Sendung um 19:30 Uhr in dem Fall von
von Moskau und den Drohnen ähm haben wir
es denn geschafft zumindest ist die
ersten Videos zu verifizieren ja die
sind immer die sind von heute die sind
dann tatsächlich diese Flugobjekte über
ja recht staatliche russische wählen in
den westlichen Vororten von Moskau
geflogen also das hatten wir dann das
konnten wir in die Sendung reinbringen
das ist ähm so das täglich Brot unserer
Arbeit
eine Frage die unsere Community auch
immer wieder bewegt und mit der wir uns
auch als Redaktion als Team hinter
dieser auseinandersetzen müssen ist die
Frage warum
ladet ihr eigentlich so wenig Experten
ein die den die den besten kritisieren
und meine Frage an Sie da vielleicht wie
schätzen sie denn die Forderungen
einiger ehemaliger Militärs und
Politiker innen ein eben keine weiteren
Waffen an die Ukraine zu liefern und
schnellere Verhandlungen mit Russland
anzustreben ja die Forderung haben wir
ja von Anfang an gehabt es gibt so ein
paar Punkte die dabei einfach umgekehrt
sind und bleiben und worauf keine
Antworten da sind ja also warum dann zum
Beispiel eine Verhandlung
das sind ein Ergebnis raus käme das ein
Frieden wäre warum das stabil sein
sollte
es gibt immer wieder die diesen Wunsch
da ich kann ihn auch total
nachvollziehen aber die Situation die
wir haben das was wir wissen über die
Motivation Russland warum dieser Krieg
geführt wird
nicht nahe dass es in irgendeiner Art
und Weise das Ziel geben könnte die ganz
schnell in Verhandlung rein bekommen das
ist der Grund warum wir auch immer sagen
es ist eigentlich eine Art von falscher
Balance zu sagen entweder verhandeln
oder Krieg führen sondern es geht darum
tatsächlich klar zu machen dass
irgendwann verhandeln die beste Option
ist um überhaupt noch etwas sozusagen
ich will nicht sagen zu gewinnen aber um
möglicherweise sein nacktes Leben
überhaupt noch lösen zu können das gilt
für Russland für die Ukraine gilt wenn
man sie nicht mehr mit Waffen liefern
würde
na dann wäre die Ukraine weg und dann
werden die Menschen tot ähm es gibt
keinen Grund anzunehmen dass es
irgendwie anders wäre und was dabei auch
hinten runterfällt ist das finde ich
ganz erstaunlich es geht ja nicht um die
Ukraine sie können auch ein ganz
egoistisches Argument machen das
passiert gerade für uns wir sind
sozusagen diejenigen die Ukraine
beliefert damit wir selber nicht kämpfen
müssen denn die kriegsansage von Moskau
ist ja nicht gegen die Ukraine als Land
nur sondern ist im Grunde genommen gegen
den Westen und gegen die Europäische
Union
was im Kontext dieser Frage auch immer
wieder auftaucht gerade zum Thema
Friedensverhandlungen ist dieser
friedensverhandlungsimpuls des
ehemaligen israelischen
Ministerpräsidenten aphthali Bennet und
das ist ja auch ein Argument was
vielleicht von Politiker in hier im Land
immer wieder aufgeworfen wird wie ist
denn ihre Einschätzung dazu diese Frage
erreicht uns ganz oft
habe ich keine Einschätzung zu habe ich
einfach recherchiert also auch das muss
man ganz klar sagen die die das
Einschätzen ist das eine das macht man
dann wenn man nicht mehr so wahnsinnig
viel Information hat oder sozusagen sagt
okay ich habe ein paar Witze und pieces
und das muss in diesem Fall ist ja sehr
sauber recherchiert worden auch von dem
ähm Kollektiv Leuten also einen Verbund
von Journalisten was ist da eigentlich
passiert und das Interessante ist dass
der ehemalige israelische Premier selbst
gesagt hat ob das jetzt alles so
geklappt hätte würde er nicht wissen
es hätte insbesondere dagegen gesprochen
was ich eben schon angesprochen habe das
ist keine Sicherheitsgarantien aus
Moskau gegeben hätte und sagen muss das
ist keine Petitesse also heute in
Frieden verzagt zu unterschreiben den
man morgen wieder einreißen kann ist vor
dem Hintergrund der Vertragstreue die
Moskau bislang gezeigt hatte den letzten
Jahren und Jahrzehnten die höchste
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Moskau sich
nicht an diesen Friedensvertrag halten
würde und damit wäre man sofort wieder
zurück bei derselben Geschichte das
Interessante ist das sind wahrscheinlich
das ist eine Nachricht von 280 Zeichen
gewesen und die ist in der Welt und es
kostet Tage Wochen das zu recherchieren
was denn eigentlich der Fall ist und sie
kriegen es nicht mehr raus aus der Welt
deswegen ist es im Grunde um etwas womit
wir das auch ein bisschen wie ein Virus
den werden wir nicht mehr los damit
müssen wir permanent umgehen und was man
einfach nur machen kann ist sich immer
wieder die Fakten bereitlegen um die
dann wieder rauszuholen zu sagen ja so
ist es eigentlich abgelaufen und
deswegen ist das was hier passiert auch
eine große Aufgabe von ja Schwarm
Intelligenz von von Informationen
zusammensammeln wie alleine könnten ohne
die Information
ja auch kein Gesamtbild gegeben das
Gesamtbild setzen sie als Medien nachher
zusammen wo wir ein Teil beitragen die
Korrespondenten was beitragen wir auch
ein Teil der sozusagen der Geschichte
und der Mechanik von Krieg und den
Ländern verstehen und aber nur das ganze
insgesamt ergibt das worauf man sich
glaube ich ein begründetes Bild über die
Lage und die Aussichten machen kann das
also soweit mal zu einer
militärstrategischen Analyse warum es
wichtig ist diese Analysen und
Recherchen auch mit in so eine Sendung
zu nehmen daran dann komme ich noch mal
zu dir du bist ja in unserer Sendung vor
allem für die menschliche Perspektive
auf diesen Krieg zuständig warum ist es
wichtig die nicht aus dem Blick zu
verlieren sollten wir auch noch so oft
über militärstrategien über Grenzposten
über angriffsstrategien reden
ich denke das ist vor allem um Menschen
geht
die sind die Opfer
geostrategische Überlegungen sind
treffen unmittelbar die Menschen und
deswegen glaube ich sollten die
weiterhin im Mittelpunkt stehen hinzu
kommt noch dass
man auf weil es gelingt Schicksal der
Menschen dort zu zeigen muss ich als
Reporter nicht einschätzen muss ich
keine Meinung bringen ich muss ich kann
einfach dieses Beispiel zeigen und die
Menschen zu Hause verstehen was kriegt
bedeutet
das für ich kann ganz normale ein gutes
Beispiel vielleicht mal anführen ähm die
Mobilisierung in der ukrainischen Armee
am Anfang hat jeder sein Dorf verteidigt
das habe ich vorhin erzählt aber das
reicht natürlich nicht aus für
systematischen Krieg die ukrainische
Regierung hat ihre Armee erhöht auf über
eine Million Soldaten dafür brauchen sie
Spezialkräfte dafür brauchen sie
Logistiker und das geht über
freiwilligen Meldungen kann man so keine
Armee aufstellen sie mobilisieren es
gibt kein Recht auf Kriegsdienst
Verweigerer eine überwältigende Mehrheit
in der Ukraine ist will das will das
Land verteidigen will auch die besetzten
Gebiete befreien aber wenn es soweit
kommt dass der Einberufungsbescheid dich
erreicht als Wehrpflichtiger Mann du
hast deine zwei Kinder du hast du bist
selbstständig hast ein Unternehmen du
weißt dass die rentenversorgung in der
Ukraine nicht so ist dass deine Eltern
damit gut leben können also die ganze
Abhängigkeit deiner Familie ist da dann
ist es ein ganz anderer eine ganz andere
Bedeutung und für diesen Mann hat hast
du alles in dem Gesicht gesehen dass er
auf der einen Seite seit Jahren
verteidigen will aber auf der anderen
Seite ist es ein ganz andere Sache wenn
er jetzt zu den Menschen gehört die nach
bachmut geschickt werden oder nach wolle
da wo Kollege dem Krüger gerade war wo
es nicht nur möglich ist oder sehr
wahrscheinlich dass du stirbst oder ein
Bein verlierst oder kriegsversehrt bist
oder traumatisiert es ist ja es ist
Krieg und das kann man glaube ich durch
solche menschlichen Geschichten gut
vermitteln das glaube ich
Gregor du machst ja jetzt schon sehr
lange diese Sendung und hast auch die
Sendung begleitet eben auf diesem Weg zu
diesem wiederkehrenden Ukraine Streams
das sind ja wirklich die Videos die mit
Abstand am meisten interessieren wir
kriegen unglaublich viele Fragen wenn
wir so eine Sendung machen hat das auch
ein Stück weit überrascht und was
glaubst Du wo sind die Hauptinteressen
der Community zu diesem Thema
die Hauptinteressen also
es hat uns
nicht überrascht weil das ist ja war ja
wirklich einschneiden und das haben wir
von Tag eins auch ja erlebt und haben
uns auch sofort hingeklemmt angefangen
bei am ersten Tag des Krieges Stimmen
zusammen Leute wir hatten die Reporter
vor Ort aber wir haben mit eigenen
redaktionellen Mitteln versucht die
Leute in der Ukraine zu erreichen in
Odessa intra kiff in Kiew in with oder
Lemberg
deren Stimme hörbar zu machen und ähm
dass das erste und das war immer und ist
auch immer nach wie vor noch unser
Hauptanliegen das mit rüberzubringen in
Mitten all der Analyse die ähm für die
User da draußen sehr sehr wichtig ist
die sehr heiß diskutiert wird deine sehr
sachlich reinzubringen und das ist immer
das ratsamste diese Themen
lassen die Köpfe rauchen und die hätten
die Gemüter da von unserer Seite immer
eine Versachlichung
und die nüchternen Informationen die
überprüften Informationen reinzubringen
das zu machen das das ist das Anliegen
und
es wird hoffentlich quittiert das wird
notiert sonst hätten wir da nicht
relativ hohe Abrufzahlen und viele Leute
die mitdiskutieren wie gesagt wir
versuchen es aber von redaktioneller
Seite immer so reinzubringen dass wir
das was daran erzählt diese menschlichen
Geschichten diese Vielschichtigkeit
bei all den
Tönen die man bekommt von Ukrainern die
auf den ersten Blick kämpferisch sind
und dahinter ist dann noch hinter der
Fassade ist noch mehr das zu zeigen das
ist das ja
sehr interessiert ist die kommt in
Teilen immer wieder und wenn ich so die
Kommentare lese und dann weitergebe an
Korrespondenten an Reporter an
ExpertInnen dann fallen mir einige Namen
immer wieder auf die wirklich konstant
an dieser Sendung dran bleiben und dann
großes Interesse war mit einer davon ist
wenn Odenthal das ist einer unserer
treuen Zuschauer bei ZDF heute live und
der hat uns einfach mal ein kleines
Feedback zu unserer Sendung gegeben
für die sehr gute Berichterstattung was
die Tagesaktualität die Auswahl
unterschiedliche Experten aber eben auch
die Einbindung der online community
angeht was man vielleicht noch machen
könnte wäre
internationale Experten und
Institutionen aus anderen Staaten
einbinden die nicht genuin westlich sind
weil das Verständnis dafür erhöhen
könnte
warum andere Staaten zu anderen
Einschätzungen kommen was die Lage in
der Ukraine angeht was die Bedeutung
angeht
ja und diese Frage oder dieses Feedback
möchte ich gleich mal mit Ihnen
besprechen wie sieht das aus wir laden
natürlich weil wir eine deutsche Sendung
sind oft deutsche Experten und
Expertinnen ein geben Sie das wenn oben
da recht dass das natürlich auch eine
gewisse Prägung mit sich bringt
inwiefern unterscheiden sich da die
Expertisen weltweit und vielleicht nicht
nur die exportieren aber speziell auch
die Einschätzung die daraus folgen
also ich glaube es hat Vor- und
Nachteile nur deutsche Experten zu
nehmen
die deutschen Experten sind sozusagen
die der deutschen Diskussion kulturell
und sprachlich näher das ist ja Vorteil
und gleichzeitig der Nachteil bei der
ganzen Geschichte also wir haben ja
sozusagen eine Art von von Schräglage
von Knick in der Pupille drinne die
andere nicht haben und ich gebe ihm
total recht wir haben zurzeit eine sehr
auf Deutschland bezogene Diskussion wir
machen ja einige Beiträge für das ZDF
auch schriftlich das mache ich mit dem
Kollegen zusammen der leider kein
Deutsch spricht der Arbeit der absolute
Ukraine ist ich wird Ihnen den permanent
gerne zu uns zur Interview geben dann
könnte ich auch weniger machen aber das
ist halt das Problem ne das ist eine
Sprachbarriere aber die Expertise ohne
die Expertise dieses Menschen könnte ich
bestimmte Sachen gar nicht machen und so
ist auch das was wir Ihnen liefern auch
immer der kollektivleistung die zustande
kommt es ist auch insofern auch da gebe
ich einen Unterricht eine
deutschlandzentrische oder eine
eurozentrische Diskussion als dass wir
sehr wenig nur hören wie in anderen
Ländern darüber nachgedacht wird und
warum das muss man auch ganz versehen
wir keine so große Mehrheit hinter der
Art und Weise in Europa oder außerhalb
Europas haben wie wir diesen Krieg
zurzeit führen und dass wir die Ukraine
so stark unterstützen
was wären denn für dich noch Punkte wo
du sagst das machen wir bisher nicht das
könntest du dir gut vorstellen
perspektivisch noch einzubauen dieser
Krieg wird uns ja noch eine Weile
beschäftigen
genau das was Sven Odendahl sagt ist ist
eine Herausforderung also würde ich
sagen Challenge accepted probieren wir
es überhaupt gar keine keine Hürde
eigentlich vor uns ein bisschen
technischer Aufwand zum Beispiel auch
ihren Kollegen mit dem Dolmetscher in
dieser Sendung zu hören machen wir
können wir auch mal machen bringt doch
vielleicht noch mal eine andere
Perspektive mit rein ähm da weiter dran
zu bleiben was wir ich habe mir die
Frage auch gestellt als ich das gehört
habe von dem User welche Perspektiven
können wir dann noch eröffnen was wir
ganz häufig gemacht haben im letzten
Jahr ist auch ähm russische
Gesprächspartner reinzuholen weniger
Experten es gibt auch nur noch wenige
die frei sprechen die sich das trauen
und trotzdem bin ich immer wieder
überrascht das ist diese Stimmen gibt
wenn man sie fragt also das ist das sind
ja nicht die Experten das ist der
Student der mit auf die Straße geht
das ist der Politiker aus St Petersburg
der eine Petition macht für die
Amtsenthebung von Putin das ist der
Anwalt der Kriegsdienstverweigerer
vertritt ähm das ist ähm der Chef der
Menschenrechtsorganisation mehr moreal
die hatten wir alle schon dabei von dem
selbst unsere Kollegen in Moskau
glaubten ähm so Leute trauen sich
inzwischen nicht mehr zu reden deren
Organisation ist verboten und trotzdem
wenn man sich fragt sind sie dabei und
das finde ich das aller wertvollste
ja ich glaube wir haben gerade erst mal
alles besprochen was man besprechen kann
zu aktuellen Nachrichtenlage aber auch
zu so meta-thema wie wir diese Sendung
alle gemeinsam gestalten und ja was ihr
von dieser Sendung erwartet ich habe zum
Schluss noch einen Kommentar aus der
Community von no Sand auf Youtube der
geht wahrscheinlich besonders an Dich da
er sagt Kriegsreporter sind Helden der
Wahrheit also sehr viel Wertschätzung
für deine Arbeit aus der Community
gibt's hier im Raum noch irgendwelche
Fragen an unsere kleine illustere Runde
das sieht nicht so aus insofern bedanke
ich mich für diese sehr spezielle und
außergewöhnliche Sendung ich hoffe ihr
seid jetzt auf dem neuesten Stand was
die Nachrichtenlage zur Ukraine angeht
und ich hoffe ihr könnt jetzt besser
nachvollziehen wie wir diese Sendung für
euch da draußen machen und ich hoffe ihr
schaltet wieder ein vielen Dank für eure
Kommentare und Fragen und bis zum
nächsten Mal bei ZDF heute live